Edd's good morning how are you
good morning Theodore how are you doing
I'm great where'd you watch the game
here in des Baux really yes like marble
you know I had people over and I told
them you guys stay on this side of the
house and leave me alone and I had my
two German Shepherds out with me and I
said if anyone comes down this hall feel
free to go for the Angels first did you
you yell at the TV when you're watching
a game
I don't yell at the TV but I have
running commentary on certain plays
calls situations I you know it's funny
because I think that's what the
Twitterverse is all about you know
instead of people yelling now they just
they tweet their things out so I was
tweeting as certain things were going on
now why did you hold out hope that
Cleveland could win when Golden State
had a seven-point lead at halftime and
Cleveland was shooting so poorly from
three-point range
just because of that he shot so bad from
three LeBron was not in attack mode
yet and yet you're still down by seven
points and I knew that Golden State was
gonna have to have a cushion going into
the fourth which they did not because
Cleveland and Kyrie and the start of
that third junior Smith did a great job
of grabbing momentum and you and I
talked about this last week even though
that they were up 3-1 in LeBron said
this in the postgame I watched a lot of
film and I changed the blueprint they
figured out that they had two best
players in this series and they knew all
along that the weakest link defensively
was going to be Steph and we should have
kind of caught glimpses of this earlier
on with Damien Lillard kind of going at
Steph Russell Westbrook so they figured
okay we're going to simplify the offense
and we're just going to put him in every
and roll situation and forced him to
switch and if they don't switch then
we're gonna have a big on them which we
saw work I redid to the big of Golden
State and LeBron attacking the paint
area
but when Steph was switched out on one
of those two they went after the weakest
leak it was old-school basketball it was
80s and 90s where they saw a weak link
defensively and they just isolated that
it's the kind of the old Don Nelson
thing let's just keep writing the same
play go after the same weak link and we
thought what happened but I felt like
Cleveland was the aggressor last night
it was it was weird how you're waiting
for Golden State to sort of be Golden
State but then I don't know if they have
an aggressive gear they have that little
you know that sort of higher octane gear
there I guess there was a difference it
felt like Cleveland was going after
everything Kevin Love got into it they
just felt like every possession was was
you know precious to them and I didn't
feel that way with Golden State today
and you just can't point to last night
they were the aggressor
Game five Game six and Game seven and
let's give a lot of credit the best
player in this series no question and he
got the MVP with LeBron James but if
there could have been a co-mvp Kyrie
Irving the pressure that he put on Steph
he was the second best player in this
series but to me the guy that kind of
goes unsung in this was Tristan Thompson
at both ends of the floor keeping balls
alive in positions for them but I
tweeted this out are you talking about
running commentary they would switch
Tristan Thompson on Steph and he took
him out of the play he didn't it was
like a boxing one and to have your
center guard the two times in VP on
switch out and basically take him out of
the offense was remarkable and that was
a great adjustment by coach Liu and that
coaching staff of we're going to trust
you you be able to move your feet and if
he gets by you will give help but he was
face guarding Steph
this inner face guarding him and the
only one shot he got was that long three
and if from the top of the key like in
the fourth quarter I think to close the
lead to within four if that's the best
stuff can do it the favor was all in
Cleveland that's why I said I'm going to
stick with my prediction because I
started this with the the Warriors and
seven but from Game five and in Game
seven situation it was the Cavs to lose
they had all the momentum and they had
the two best players we talked about
this last week they had the two best
players on the floor every game
especially starting in Game five
he's Reggie Miller NBA on TNT analyst
joining us Dan Patrick show Jay Williams
who played in the league
former Dukie he tweeted out that he
thinks LeBron is better than Michael
Jordan what does he mean by that well I
mean that anytime you bring in Michael
Jordan and especially with LeBron James
you're gonna have a firestorm because
you have so many loyalists to both of
these guys and I was I'm ready to come
on your show because we had this
conversation I believe that last time
you and the Dan Nets were in LA for that
one of the LA shows and we talked about
our starting fires who would be our
all-time starting five and we got into
the Larry Bird versus LeBron James the
small forward position
right now I have Michael Magic Larry
Hakeem and Kareem those were my starting
five of all-time
today I'm I'm and you know how much I
love Larry Joe you know how much I
patterned my game after Larry Joe right
you know he was my coach in Indiana I
would do anything for Larry Joe but I've
got to let it go down I've got to let it
go I really do have what he did for
Cleveland and that city and that state
and that team I've got to let it go he
is in my top five now he'll never to me
he'll never get ahead of Michael and
he'll never get ahead of Magic
and you'll probably never get ahead of a
Kareem but everyone else he's the fourth
best player that he's the fourth best
player now special consideration to Tim
Duncan special consideration to Kobe but
LeBron is I have to let it go
Oh Mary Jo I love you but I've got to
let it go down but why can't LeBron be
recognizes better than Jordan when it's
all said and done six for six
that's rain that's it six for six times
there six times I want and six times I
was Finals MVP yeah but if I go until
someone does that or come close to that
no six times I went six times I won oh
and oh by the way six times I was Finals
MVP but if I look at LeBron and his his
resume is gonna be different because you
know of the finals that he's lost but
let's say he wins one or two more and
now now he's knocking on the door to
Magic Johnson is he a better all-around
player than Jordan
maybe that's what Jay Williams is saying
here is it is is LeBron better at both
ends of the floor than Michael oh man
that black guy could get it done at the
defensive end - oh yeah but not the way
LeBron does I mean that block on
Iguodala last night was I mean it
brought back like I'm sitting on the
couch and I thought hey Shaun Prince was
in my living room I really did I like
where did you come from and look he
changes the game obviously at both ends
but so did MJ I know this is the one I
can't I can't let that one go six times
I went six times I want and oh by the
way six times I was Finals MVP and as
great as LeBron is in some of these
finals he has disappeared
he's great don't get me wrong what did I
just proclaim you know he's a my my top
five but there's been some finals that
he's disappeared
can you ever say that about number 23
that black cat in Chicago
did he ever disappear
any of his finals he had a couple of bad
games but I don't know if that's
considered disappearing well of course
you're gonna have a couple bad yeah yeah
but but if we're choosing sides LeBron
and Michael right now would Michael ever
get swept in a Finals game no did LeBron
get swept in a Finals game before yeah
yes well but reg you're at are you
asking me well here I know but you got
to be fair to LeBron that's the worst
team that ever went to the finals that
supporting family which is why he has
surpassed in my opinion and I can't it
pains me to say this because I patterned
my game after Larry Joe it pains me to
say this trust me you know how much I
love Larry Bird come on now
it hurts to the core for me to admit
that LeBron now is on my top five it
pains me I love them I respect his
talent but I was always holding out hope
for for Larry Joe but Larry Joe has
three chips but there was a lot of chips
in Boston before he got there this is
something special that LeBron has done
for a city and state 52 years and he
backed up his promise of bringing a
championship and I said this on your
show years ago when he made that
decision winning one ship in Cleveland
is like winning three in Miami or
Chicago or New York or LA because it
means more in small markets people they
bleed they die they follow they they
worship these guys so to win one in a
small market and especially a suffering
market like Cleveland it's to me that's
like winning three Jim Wright will come
back I'm gonna ask Reggie about the
Cavaliers off season including LeBrons
future and the Warriors off season
including Steph Curry's possible surgery
continue with Reggie the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you